I think you know and this is all hey I
love a good debate about if jokes are
good or bad I I think he should perform
I have no doubt in the next year and a
half
he'll be at Madison Square Garden doing
three shows in a row so this whole like
Lewis struggling thing you will make 80
million dollars on the next tour okay
this all lands with him triumphant in
some way maybe not with everybody but
that's where it lands but in the
meantime when you're somebody that's
hurt people it's weird to think your
subjects should be people who are
hurting you know trans people they
commit suicide they get murdered at a
crazy rate so it's not really the
moments ago I'm put out by the fact that
you want to be called by a certain name
yeah a lot of people have done that bit
by the way so it's not even that
interesting a bit to medium change it's
his bit went on that wall kid I thought
was the thing he did about calling me
the I'm a location and the punch line on
I'm a location it made me laugh out loud
it was a hilarious I don't even
trans people okay so you know and I get
it and we all have that in our lives are
like okay we're adjusting to something
and so I guess Louise doing that it's
hard to adjust to a woke country type of
thing but also there are people who are
like I'm getting murdered my friends all
could be suicide maybe it's not the
moment to call me a jackass because I
want respect no I don't believe that I I
mean I know of course if they if life
was that literal sure but then if you
made a movie about trans people being
murdered nobody would have a problem
with it if Stephen King killed trans
people in his books nobody would have a
problem with it so as artists as
comedians the only way we can address
something without being virtue signaling
idiots is to try to be funny with it
however we see fit
so I like barbarism in comedy I like
horrible thick barber I love that word
it makes me laugh and it has never once
made me look at a subject differently
than I looked at it as a human being and
no comedians ever made me look at
something differently as a human being
so Louise being horrible about parkland
won't make me feel one ounce less
empathy for those people that that
happen to one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the SiriusXM a